well we begin with great news the
governor of Georgia Brian Kemp
courageously signed a bill into law
yesterday that outlaws all abortion
after the heart beat can be detected so
that that takes care of a great number
of abortions not all of them but many of
them and there have been boycott threats
and things from Hollywood and other
organizations and industries saying that
they're gonna boycott the state if this
bill is signed into law but Kent made it
clear that he's not going to be
intimidated and that he's going to
follow throughout his pro-life
convictions anyway so he deserves to be
commended for that and all of the
pro-life legislators down there in
Georgia deserve to be commended now the
court of course the left is having
conniption fits over this as you would
expect I'm not going to bother going
through and giving you examples of the
things that they're saying Alexandria
Casey of Cortez of course is having a
tantrum about it and all the usual
suspects does it doesn't I'm not going
to go through that because doesn't
really matter and pro aborts you know
they have two or three arguments at
their disposal and a whole bunch of
straw men and they just shout them
incessantly it's the same thing over and
over and over again and they keep
shouting them no matter how often you
engage with their points and debunk the
points it doesn't matter they'll just
keep going back to the well over and
over and over again so at a certain
point it's like what's what's what
reason is there even to get into the
specifics of what their arguments are
you already know what their arguments
are it's a bunch of men that are trying
to control women's bodies and blah blah
blah I will just say one thing though
there will you know and back in a second
the thing is that with the pro boards to
use these straw men arguments all though
it's men trying to control women you're
trying to control women's bodies you
know all the different straw men you if
you you can't be again you can't be
against abortion if you're not willing
to adopt all of the unwanted babies we
talked about that a few days ago so
basically you're not allowed to be
opposed to somebody's murder unless you
are able to purse
we feed and clothe those people so which
means that you're not allowed to be
opposed to almost everyone's murder
because you personally probably don't
have the ability to clothe and feed
seven billion people right but all these
all these strummin the thing is if the
person who makes these straw man
arguments the reason why they're using
strummin is that they are intellectually
lazy non thinkers and if you're an
intellectually lazy non thinker it's you
really can't be engaged with because if
you're not willing to think if you're
not willing to think beyond claiming
that the pro-life movement is a
patriotic patriarchal conspiracy if
that's the most you're willing to think
if you're not willing to engage your
mind and really try to understand okay
why is it maybe it's not just that these
are a bunch of men who are trying to
control women it could there be some
other reason possibly why someone might
be against abortion if you're not
willing to think like that or to think
at all then there's there's no
conversation can be had you have to be
willing to turn on your brain first but
there's there's one thing one thought I
want to share there will now it's very
very simple concept here there will
there will now be children born in
Georgia who otherwise would not have
been born right this law will indeed
prevent many women from getting
abortions if it was not going to prevent
many women for getting abortions then
pro-abortion people wouldn't be freaking
out about it they try to have it both
ways here they'll say on one hand the
law is terrible because it's going to
prevent all these women from getting
abortions and then on the other hand
they'll say it's not going to prevent
anyone because now they'll go to the
back alley and they'll get back alley
abortion so they try to have it both
ways but they know that yes it will
prevent not every woman but it will
prevent a significant number of women
from getting abortions all right so what
does that mean well it means that in say
a year's time or two years time there
will be a number of I think the law goes
into effect in 2020 actually so in let's
say
three years time or four years time
there will be a number of babies in
Georgia living born babies who would not
be there would not exist if not for this
law so if you're against this law are
you willing to look at a baby born in
Georgia in the year 2021 and say he
shouldn't exist it would be better if he
did not exist are you willing to do that
I'm not and that's that's the point here
the the terrible dystopian Handmaid's
Tale result of this Georgia law is that
there will be more babies that's it
that's the result okay that's the
dystopia that we are heading into it's a
world where there are a few more babies
babies that are allowed to live rather
than being killed
now the left can mourn over that if they
want they can treat it like some sort of
catastrophe but you know I I'm not going
to because I love babies I think babies
are awesome I love life I think life is
awesome and that's how I live I can't
imagine living other what any other way
I can't imagine being the sort of person
who would get upset at the idea of more
babies being born I imagine being that
kind of person it's incredible
alright I said I wasn't going to bother
going over the left reaction to this law
but I do have to play one clip for you
just one clip here is a debate between
Christine Quinn and Rick Santorum on CNN
last night I answered it numerous times
when when a woman gets pregnant that is
not a human being inside of her it's
part of her body and this is about a
woman having full agency and control of
her body and making decisions about her
body and what is part of her body with
medical
you're not you're asking provocative
things that are trying to make the
people angry but what's done and that's
okay all I'm saying is you guys go too
far when you pervert the facts and we
have the president United States saying
that a baby is born at the end of
full-term swaddle in a blanket and they
decide whether or not to execute it I
know so Chris Cuomo says you guys
pervert the facts and and who is he
referring to
well he's referring to pro lifers of
course you guys are pervert you guys are
perverting the fact of course meanwhile
a guest on his show just said seconds
earlier that an unborn baby is not a
human being isn't a human being well if
that's the case then I mean my god my
wife is pregnant and III thought she was
pregnant with a baby this whole time I
thought she had a baby in her womb this
whole time apparently it's a space alien
you know yet I had no idea I mean I'm
not mad that it's a space alien I it
could be kind of cool to have a space
alien around the house but I think the
doctor should have mentioned that at the
ultrasound that's all I'm saying you
know the doctor should have said hey by
the way this is a parasitic alien
infestation not a pregnancy I feel like
that's the kind of disclosure that
doctors should make or the other
possibility is of course that my wife is
is actually pregnant with a human and
that every pregnant woman in history has
been pregnant with a human yeah yeah I
think that's probably it I think yeah I
think that's I think that's gotta be it
this is such a speaking of bad arguments
okay it's one thing to claim that the
unborn human the unborn baby is human
but is not a person okay that's a stupid
argument too and we've talked about that
we've talked about how to address that
but at least with that argument you're
pretending to have some kind of respect
for the basic biological facts here and
you realize that you can't deny that
it's a human so instead you're trying to
parse make some distinction between
human and person you're playing kind of
a grammatical game a word game that's a
bad argument but to just go full gusto
here and say it's naughty it's not even
a human well that's I mean there is no
credible scientist in the world who will
endorse that idea I don't care how
liberal they are how pro-abortion they
are you will not find a single credible
sane scientist who will say yeah you're
right not a human being there are two
ways to know that it's a human being
okay here's here's the spoiler alert
number one DNA it has human DNA that
makes it a human number two you don't
even need to do a DNA test here because
we know it's a human because it was
created by two humans so I guess to give
Christine Queen a little bit of a birds
and bees lecture here you know okay
because I guess her parents never did
you see when uh when a man and a woman
love each other and they get together
they they have sexual relations and then
a pregnancy occurs well that pregnancy
is going to be another human it's not
going to be a carrot or a moose or a
chair or the color blue you know it's
going to be a human because that's two
humans in the midst of a sexual act and
the procreative Act it can only create
another human sorry I don't know how
else to explain this I don't know you
still confused Christine Quinn I mean I
don't know how else to it's just too
that's all that two people can do they
can only create other people they can't
create any other kind of thing that's
that's his that's as basic as I can get
it's pretty remedial here you say oh
it's a part of the woman's body yeah but
it's not though you say except the the
problem with that argument is that it's
completely stupid it's just not part of
the woman's body I mean it's not it's it
is entirely different bodies apart
let's my arm is a part of my body okay
so you see look at my arm here this is
my arm it's called an arm it's my left
arm to be specific and it's a part of my
body now here's one of the ways that you
know it's a part of my body it's that
this arm will never be anything but an
arm you see you could cut it off and
then I just won't have an arm anymore
but if you were to cut off my arm and
please don't but if you did and my arm
was just laying there on the floor it's
not gonna turn into a camel or a cat it
won't turn into anything just it's just
gonna be it adjust it will decay it's
just an arm right it and when it's
connected to my body it will it will
remain an arm forever it will never
become anything else so if there is a
part of your body that magically after
nine months turns into a whole new
person well that's a pretty good
indication that that part of your body
was never a part of your body you see
just a little little basic signs for it
for you guys today hopefully I was able
to clear that up for Christine Quinn
all right let's stay on the realm the
pro-life realm here for a moment
Brian Sims the Democratic rep in
Pennsylvania who's been harassing and
bullying pro-lifers and who sparked our
big rally that were going to have down
up there for me in Pennsylvania on
Friday
11:44 Locust Street at 11 a.m. that's
where we're all going to be but Brian
Sims yesterday he recorded what has been
described as an apology but it's an
interesting apology because it's missing
something and I want you to watch this
and watch very closely see if you can
spot what's missing
hi everyone representative Brian Sims
here and I'm actually up in our Capitol
for this week's legislative session but
I stepped off the floor for a moment
because I've received a lot of feedback
about a video I posted last week and I
want to provide some background you see
I've lived across the street or next
door to this particular Planned
Parenthood one of the most heavily
protested Planned Parenthood's in
America for the last 15 years I've seen
men and women and teens try to go there
for routine health care for checkups for
pap smears for breast exams for STD
screenings and yes for abortions in fact
it's where I even treat for my own
life-saving prep medication and I'm
grateful for the services that they
provide I've also spent the last seven
years serving as a volunteer patient
escort at this Planned Parenthood and I
have seen firsthand the insults the
slurs the attacks and the racism that
those protestors emit mostly young girls
going there for clinical care care that
those of us in the outside can never
understand and last week was no
different
what I should have shown you in that
video was protestors gathered together
to pray at not to silently pray for
people coming in and out of Planned
Parenthood as they intercepted them and
harassed them in my years what Planned
Parenthood I've seen women and girls
circle that block two three four times
before finally driving away because they
know that they weren't going to get in
because of those protestors but as a
Planned Parenthood volunteer and as a
supporter I fully understand respect and
appreciate the non-engagement policy
that they have and I would never want to
do anything that interferes with the
care that they're providing to their
patients as an activist and an advocate
I know why pushing back against
harassment and discrimination or a must
even when they're uncomfortable but last
week I was
patient escort I was a neighbor and a
concerned citizen and I was aggressive I
know that two wrongs don't make a right
and I can do better and I will do better
for the women of Pennsylvania yeah the
missing thing the thing that's missing
from this apology is an apology
that's what's missing he never once
apologizes I don't know how it is that
this has been described as an apology he
never says I'm sorry
or I apologize never says those words he
never expresses any anything that even
comes close to resembling an apology
in fact he doubles down he continues to
smear pro-lifers or schmear them as he
might say and so this this is not just a
classic non-apology apology see a
non-apology apology is when you say
something like I'm sorry if you were
offended or you know something like that
but this is not even that this is just
another attack on pro-lifers this is him
continuing the smear campaign
this is him continuing to to him
doubling down on what he initially did
he's justifying it the only little bit
of regret he expresses is for the
inconvenience he's caused Planned
Parenthood that's there's a little tinge
of regret and it's for that but that's
it so Brian we're still coming 11:00
a.m. on Friday
11:44 Locust Street will be there and I
really hope to see you there though I
tend to doubt that I will
all right so Megan McCain was on Seth
Meyers last night things got a little
bit testy watch a little bit of this
clip when asked about Ilhan Omar
congressman from Minnesota you know she
was in Scituate you were a very vocal
about some of her tweets people were
upset thought it was anti-semitic
language she has since unequivocally
apologized for them and then after that
there was this tragic synagogue shooting
in California
once again sort of on a Sunday show of
Sunday news show brought up her tweets
again in the context of that shooting on
George Stephanopoulos I'm George
Stephanopoulos yeah and I just wonder
because I do think that's it's fairly
dangerous and you brought it up after
Congress a woman Oh Marta also had some
death threats against her do you think
you know she's obviously now stated she
needs to be more careful with their
language don't you think other people
who talk about her need to be a little
bit more thoughtful as well or do you
stand by those comments of tying her to
this her rhetoric to the synagogue
shooting I don't think I tied her to it
in particular I think that I'm calling
out what I see is anti-semitic language
and when you're talking about but even
after she apologized for it I do want to
establish the timeline I don't I think
that Democrats are are hedging on this
and I think it's very dangerous and I
think Chuck Schumer and I are in
alignment about Israel's stance and in
geopolitical politics I think it's of
the utmost importance and I think she is
bringing her party to the extreme
extremism on this and I think we have to
look to Europe and what's happening over
there and that there you know in in the
British politics anti-semitism is very
common and I see it happening over there
and I worry about it happening over here
I stand by every single thing I said and
if that makes me unpopular in this room
or in front of you so be it popular Here
I am trying to you know find the common
ground on this because I do think one of
the I think we could both agree by her
language about 9/11 I thought it was
taken out of context and I think if you
watched that whole president Trump the
same same leverage the same thing well I
would say that Donald Trump is certainly
in no position to criticize her language
on 9/11 based on the things that he said
about 9/11 right so this is a comedy
show folks this is this is comedy now
conservatives are making a thing out of
this exchange between Seth Meyers and
Megan McCain because of Meyers political
bias notice I know you know he's a
left-wing bias and all that and that's
true but I'm a lot more concerned about
the fact that this is late night comedy
but it isn't funny you know
I will K with the comedian being a
left-winger so maybe that's where I
depart from some other conservatives out
there where you know it doesn't upset me
that these comedians are all liberal I'm
fine with that
a liberal person theoretically can still
be funny and if they're funny they're
funny that's fine
as long as they're funny the trouble
though with these partisan hacks on
late-night is that they aren't funny
they're not even trying to be funny and
that's the unforgivable sin for a
comedian isn't it to not be funny it's
like you know I I don't care if my
plumber is a liberal so long as he's
good at fixing my plumbing if he can't
do that then he's sort of worthless as a
plumber
and if he can't fix my plumbing and he
delivers left-wing lectures to me then
that's that's insult to injury why is it
that comedy has died in the Trump era
why is it that all these you know these
late night shows were never great but
they did used to be at least
entertaining you know amusing and
they're not even that anymore and why is
that I think a lot of it goes into well
there's there's a lot that goes into it
but one answer certainly is that these
guys really really hate Donald Trump as
I'm sure you've noticed and you can't
really be funny about something if you
hate it in order to make funny jokes
about something or someone you have to
have some kind of affection for the
target of your humor because if you have
some kind of affection for it then then
you can relate to it and if you can
relate to it then you can understand it
and in order to be funny you need to
understand what you're making jokes
about because that's a fundamental part
of wit and so there's that's the
problems that they they they absolutely
hate Donald Trump with a blind hatred
and by extension they hate his
supporters they hate conservatives they
hate all
these people and so they they just can't
be funny I mean they can they can sneer
and they can mock but they can't go
beyond that because of their hatred as
it turns out you know hatred and hatred
and comedy really don't mix as it turns
out
speaking of comedy I've been wanted to
talk about this for a few days there's a
an article in The Daily wire about a
woman who married herself and this is
goes back to an article originally in
the telegraph about a 42 year old woman
who was talk about the best the best day
of her life is when she married herself
it says in the reading from the daily
wire says Melissa Denton a two-time
divorcée was with two children writes
the idea to marry myself came to me in
January last yes last year when I was at
work one day three weeks before on
Christmas Eve I had received a text
message from my boyfriend of five and a
half years I can't do this anymore it's
over it said it was devastating and left
me in a funk unable to eat smile or
sleep seizing upon the idea of marrying
herself Denton recalls a TV interview
with Sophie Tanner who had married
herself in May 15 on in May 2015
Denton writes I was so down and knew
that I needed to learn to love myself
before I'd be able to attract the right
people into my life for years I had
poured myself into relationships after
relationship losing myself in the
process blah blah blah so there was a
she got a ring for herself she there was
a wedding date and she invited her
friends and family they had a maid a DJ
a lot of a live band karaoke get that a
huge vegan fest I know you're shocked by
that this woman's a vegan I know that
surprises you and people actually came
out to celebrate this woman's marriage
tour so including some ex-boyfriends
also came apparently now I mean
obviously this is crazy and it does show
again that you know this is someone who
is completely self-absorbed
literally in love with themselves and
her marriages and relationships aren't
working out so this goes back to that
thing of if you find that your
relationships never work and that you've
got a whole string of ex-boyfriends and
then a whole string of ex-husbands at a
certain point you probably need to ask
yourself what is the common denominator
like in every one of these failed
relationships there's one common thread
that binds them all together what is
that oh yeah it's me
I'm the thing that I am the the common
ingredient in all of these failed
relationships
maybe there's something wrong with me
and maybe that thing is among probably
other things self-absorption that could
be it
you know she mentions there you have to
learn to love yourself before you can
love other people that is such utter BS
of all the modernist cliches that might
that might actually be the worst because
it's not only stupid because but it's
harmful I mean this idea you have to if
the war work on loving yourself before
you can love other people first of all
what does it mean to work on loving
yourself do you what do you so you just
sit guy just sit here at the table and
just work on loving myself what I do
just think try to think happy thoughts
okay I'm gonna love myself let me think
about it hmm let me say obviously if I
can generate some love for myself what
does that even mean how do you do that
or do you have to go and have a marry
yourself and have this whole big pageant
the whole idea of me the whole concept
is meaningless and aside from that
you've got to see the problem with tying
your feelings about yourself to your
ability to love other people because
then what what if you managed somehow to
love yourself at least for them for the
time being
and then you go out and get married and
you have kids well what happens on the
days when you wake up and these days
will come where you'll wake up feeling
not so great about yourself there gonna
be days where you're a little bit down
in the dumps there gonna be days when
when you don't love yourself quite as
much so what are you gonna say to your
spouse and kids oh sorry guys I can't
love you today because I I can't love
you today because I'm just not feeling
great about myself no love is an act of
will it's a choice that you make and you
can and should make that choice
regardless of how you feel about
yourself so I love my wife and kids all
the time I don't I don't even like
myself sometimes I mean III there it's
my feelings about myself go up and down
it's not it's not a steady thing I think
we're all like that right you're not
gonna feel great about yourself all the
time every day and you shouldn't try
every day to conjure those feelings
about yourself you know you know the
best thing to do it's just to stop
thinking about yourself put that to the
side and focus on other people focus on
the things outside of you focus on the
external realities if you're not feeling
great about yourself well that's that is
a perfect time to go and and focus on
loving especially focus on loving your
wife loving your husband your kids and
then maybe in the process of going
through the acts and making the choice
of loving other people maybe in the
midst of that you'll find yourself
feeling better about yourself you see so
the love for yourself
becomes more of a byproduct of your love
for other people not the starting point
all right um finally before we answer
some emails I had a thought I wanted to
share speaking of families and and and
loving you know your family and all that
good stuff
I don't thought I want to show you know
I took my five-year-old son fishing a
couple of days ago and we went in the
late afternoon we stayed out until dark
we didn't catch anything neither of us
did and that's partly my fault because
usually when I take my kids fishing
which I've done in the past
I'll have them they'll be using a bobber
with a you know a little Nightcrawler
like a little worm and you just you cast
it out there just you let you let it sit
until a little pan fish or something
comes and jumps on the hook and it's
easy to catch fish that way you catch a
lot of little small fish that way but
this time I thought I want to teach my
boy
real fishing so I had him using an
adult-sized rod plastic lures the kind
of lure where you cast it out you reel
it back in you have to work the rod a
little bit and try to put some action in
the lure and try to get fish attracted
to it and that's how you catch bass
that's how you catch good size bass but
you're ruling out the tiny fish which
means that there's a chance that you
won't catch anything at all whereas if
you had use the bobber and everything
you could have caught some small fish
anyway that's now I'm getting off into
fishing that's not really the point the
point is he had a great time
we both did even though we didn't catch
anything so it didn't matter that we
didn't catch anything afterwards we went
got some pizza got him home way past his
bedtime but on the way home as we were
driving my son told me that he wants to
be a great fisherman like me one day he
wants to be a great fisherman like Daddy
one day is what he said and when he said
that you know I I I said oh thanks buddy
you'll get there one day
and in my head though I was kind of
laughing because I didn't catch a single
thing all day I mean being a fisherman
like me is not a high bar to get over so
I thought it was funny that he was that
after witnessing me get goose egg like
that for three hours he was thinking I
want to be a great what
grated fishing like that but then as I
thought more about it I realized that
there's something kind of profound about
what my son said there because as dad's
our sons idolize us they admire
everything about us even our failures so
my son was watching me fail at fishing
but that's not what he saw you know
that's not what he was focused on he was
thinking about he all he was thinking
about is that he wants to be just like
me and do what I do and I think that's a
really good reason to take this father
hood job seriously
you know because our sons are watching
us like hawks all the time they're
picking up lessons every day even when
we aren't trying to teach them lessons
and that's a humbling thought and it's
kind of scary because I started to think
to myself well ok if he if he was
watching me suck at fishing and he took
a few bad fish fishing pointers from me
accidentally it's not the worst thing in
the world
but what about other moments in my life
where I you know I'm displaying
certain more serious flaws and he's
watching that and picking up on that if
he sees me lose my temper or something
like that or have or be impatient well
he's gonna be watching that too and
thinking I want to be just like Daddy
thinking well that's that's what men do
that's what it means to be I want to be
a man and that's what a man does so I
should be like that so it's a humbling
thought and like I said a scary thought
but also also beautiful when you think
about it that we have you know that kind
of responsibility and that we have
people in our lives who admire us and
love us that much and look up to us so
it's a incredible responsibility one
other thing about fishing with my son
that I was thinking about is I noticed
something else on a slightly different
note you know my son has a lot of
trouble paying attention he's very
rambunctious very energetic he struggles
with the ABCs and 123s and all that
because he can't sit still and pay
attention for very
but I took him out to the lake and he
worked on his casting for three hours I
mean he must have made a hundred casts
and he stayed focused on he worked at it
it's focused and so we say about our
boys a lot of the time that they can't
pay attention they can't focus we use
these words like I just used but I think
they can they just pay attention to
different sorts of things and they can
learn they just learn differently
they're interested in different things
they have a different style of learning
now you might say that it's more
important for him to pay attention to
the ABCs and one through threes than it
is for him to learn about fishing but is
it really I mean fishing is a useful
skill and and he's learning other things
at the same time I taught him about bass
beds where the mommy bass lay their eggs
we talked about the different kinds of
things that fish eat and how you change
the color of the lure depending on the
the clarity of the water and depending
on the time of day and all that kind of
stuff we talked about how bass like to
be around structures like stumps and big
rocks and laid down trees we talked
about how they come up into the shallows
when it gets cooler and there's and
there's less light and so he learned
like he had a whole biology lesson right
there at the lake and he learned a skill
at the same time so if I tried to sit
him down on a chair and just lecture him
about fish he would not have been able
to absorb anything I said but take him
out to the lake let him see let him
touch let him move around let him
explore let him do something while he's
learning and and and what do you know he
learns and I think it's probably that
that way for a lot of a lot of young
boys a lot of young boys who have been
consigned to the label of learning
disabled or whatever else know they can
learn they just don't learn like that
they learn differently and that's okay
all right let's look at a couple emails
now this is from Jennifer Matt Walsh Oh
at gmail
I'm Matt Walsh over Gmail that comments
from Jennifer as an OBGYN resident I
have been involved in the delivery of
over 400 babies and I can only recall
maybe two dozen couples who didn't know
the gender of their baby beforehand in
my experience the surprise deliveries
are way more fun and emotionally
powerful than the ones where the parents
already know what they're going to have
I absolutely intend for my future
pregnancies to be surprises are you and
your wife going to find out your gender
find out the gender of your new baby
before his or her birth or do you want
it to be a surprise did you know the
genders of your other kids beforehand
I'd be willing to bet you've never
hosted a gender reveal party but I'm
curious to know your thoughts on that as
well
yeah your bet is a safe one I have never
done a gender reveal party and I would
never do one or attend one I find the
whole concept mystifying honestly I mean
I couldn't possibly care less about the
gender of any child that any of my
friends or family might be having and
it's not that I don't care about their
kids it's just I don't have like it I
don't have a preference for what gender
my sister has it's so it's not I I just
I don't get it
I'm happy for them they're having a kid
but I'm supposed to go to a party and be
thrilled about whatever gender it is it
doesn't make any sense
if it's a girl great if it's a boy great
but at a gender-reveal party when the
blue confetti comes down or however they
reveal it I'm supposed to go it's a boy
oh my gosh I had no idea it's a huge
surprise that's so exciting
no it's really not that awesome are
amazing it was a 50/50 chance and it
ended up being a boy great good for you
so I don't understand that the
gender-reveal party is to me silly but
we did find out the gender beforehand we
do we do we do find out the gender
before him and I also don't understand
not wanting to know the gender before
it's fine if people don't want to know I
can be fun to get that surprise I guess
when the baby is born but your child in
the womb is your child right it's
whether it's your son or daughter it's
your son or daughter and it doesn't
become your child at birth so why
wouldn't you want to know what gender
your child is in the womb I mean you
might as well say I don't want to know
the gender of the child is for the first
year now don't tell me I don't want to
know don't tell me I want to be
surprised in the first birthday what of
course there are parents who basically
do that now or they say no is it because
the child's gonna choose their own
gender but putting those wackos to the
side yeah so I can understand one anyway
look people do it however they want it's
there is no right or wrong answer but
for me it just seems to me that that's
my kid and I'd like to know everything I
can about them right now
why wait all right from Katherine says
in a handful of relationships I I've
known that ended in divorce all included
adultery but only one involved the
husband cheating on his wife the rest
were wives cheating on husbands in most
cases the wife was career driven and in
all but one there were kids involved
this eats at me significantly especially
since one of the cheating wives was my
own career obsessed mother why is it
that women seem to cheat so much in
relationships and why do they always
claim victim when they've been caught
well I don't know if women cheat more
men cheat more I don't know if I would
suspect it's probably about even it's a
kind of a human failing that I think
stretches across both genders but I
don't know what the stats say on that a
couple of observations it's it's no
surprise that cheaters claim victimhood
status someone with a victim mentality
is someone who is self-absorbed right
they're always the victim because
everything's about them everything is a
conspiracy about them and they feel like
they're entitled to be happy and
satisfied all the time and whoever they
happen to be around whoever's in their
life whoever is in their orbit well the
job the primary job of those people is
to make them happy and especially in a
marriage
these self-absorbed people think that my
spouse's sole purpose in life is to make
me
that's it they have no other function
it's all about me and so somebody with
that mentality it's no surprise that
they would then go cheat and feel
entitled to do so because if their
spouses and making them happy then they
think well I have a right to go and be
happy somewhere else because this is all
about me and my happiness is the most
important thing in the universe and then
they can also feel like they've been
victimized at the same time because they
could say to their spouse well how dare
you get mad at me you didn't make me
happy this is your fault so that's where
that comes from and it's also no
surprise that career-obsessed people
cheats men or women because of course
there's nothing wrong with caring about
your career nothing wrong with that but
if your career is the only thing you
care about well that's just another way
of saying that you are the only thing
you care about because your career is
mostly about you and your own
advancement your own success and so if
that becomes the the focal point of your
life then your marriage is going to take
a backseat it's going to have a
secondary status and if your marriage
has a secondary status then if your
marriage is secondary and you're
spending all day focused on something
that has nothing to do with your
marriage well then that's at that point
if you stay with that mentality it's
it's almost a certainty that you'll
cheat eventually all right we got to
wrap things up here and well I'll read
this one sis a no name provided says I'm
a big fan of your show I'm a Christian
and conservative as well I recently got
a minute to Harvard Law School I want to
thank you for being part of the
motivation and installation of faith
that helped me get get here I was a poor
black kid from the project's listening
to you taught me what it was to be a man
and achieved from sleeping in the back
of the 2003 Ford Focus to getting a job
and getting my s together
thank you friend I can't ever let you
know how much you changed my life
there were days when I didn't even want
to live ashamed and embarrassed
something about listening to your show
this past year made it worth it never
stop what you're doing I hope one day I
can have a show like yours and impact
people in a similar way God
last brother Wow well that's I am blown
away thank you for that thank you for
that for that for that feedback and also
I feel like I don't deserve any credit
at all though because you're sleeping in
the back of a car you're starting with
nothing you're achieving you're not
complaining you're not making yourself a
victim you've taken your life into your
own hands and climbing your way to
success I mean that that is all just
just to be clear that is 100% totally
you but whatever small little tiny role
I could play and motivating you I'm
grateful for that role so thank you for
that all right we'll end on that sappy
note thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed today on
the Ben Shapiro show president Trump
declares executive privilege over the
unredacted Mullah report and Democrats
escalate impeachment talk that's today
on the bench Shapiro show